et il ne reste vraiment plus beaucoup
disponibilités
a déjà été dépassée 6 fois dans la
capitale alors qu'en 2003 juste avant la
canicule qui avait frappé la France cela
n'avait été le cas qu'à deux reprises la
première quinzaine de juin a été la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée à la station
de Paris Montsouris avec une moyenne de
21,9 degrés dépassant les données de
2003 de quoi présager d'un été
caniculaire si vous n'avez ni cave ni
terrain le patron s'est lancé sur le
business de la colocation de bunker
à partager avec 150 personnes moyennant
un loyer mensuel de 249 euros
alors en fait des frais de réservation
c'est pas des réservations c'est des
prêts une concession pour une durée de
10 ans madame souhaite prêter 4 places
dans le premier bunker du genre soit
1000 euros par mois tout compris
le cambriolage tout le monde en a parlé
en disant c'est vrai c'était pas vrai ce
qu'on regarde
un sac poubelle qui était au vent
c'était très passionnant sauf que comme
je n'avais pas les images moi ça sonnait
ça sonnait ça sonnait mais ce qui est
très rigolo c'est qu'il y a plein de
gens gentils qui ont dit alors ça va
est-ce que ça va là il est persuadé
qu'une catastrophe naturelle va se
produire alors en attendant il ne veut
dépendre de personne il faut pas
toujours compter sur le gouvernement ou
les instituts et voilà parce qu'à un
moment donné si vraiment il va arriver
quelque chose mais ils pourront pas
donner à manger et s'occuper tout le
monde c'est pas possible alors il y a
tous les autres sur le sur tous les cas
je vous jure pardon j'en fais deux
secondes parce que je les ai pas copier
je voulais pas quand même montrer
comment ils étaient mais alors et ben
c'est bien fait et ben comme ça
il voit ce que c'est la France
il voit alors que c'était un sac
poubelle c'était pas un arabe
ça fait combien de temps
c'est la première fois un poisson mort
depuis 2 mois et encore là exemple avec
ce concept étonnant où ce sont vos
poissons qui font pousser vos légumes
grâce à leur propre déjections
[Musique]
tu es un peu un frigo vivant on peut
utiliser les légumes enfin manger les
légumes et manger les poissons
[Musique]
un mélange excrément et du
lavé également de l'urine avec de
l'acide urique et taches blanches et les
premières selles qui sont en train de
sortir et contre les attaques nucléaires
Gad projette un jour de commercialiser
ses prototypes de masques à gaz donc
après on retire cette bague là pour
respirer il y en a pour toute la famille
avec biberon intégré pour les plus
petits et même une version spéciale pour
nos animaux de compagnie donc ça peut
être un chien ça peut être un chat
sur des images en noir et blanc on voit
en effet ce qui pourrait ressembler à un
extraterrestre dans l'arrière cours
d'une maison à Las Vegas il est accroupi
il a un visage ovale honnêtement il est
un peu effrayant d'ailleurs sur la vidéo
on a la retranscription de l'échange
téléphonique entre la personne qui le
film est Polisse ce cours l'homme dit
être terrifié par ses yeux brillants il
y a 15 ans si l'obérus connais avait 70
ans son épouse à l'époque Véronica Lario
une ancienne actrice déclare qu'elle ne
peut plus vivre avec ses lieux Berluscon
elle le dit publiquement pourquoi parce
que dit-elle Silvio Berlusconi couche
avec des filles qui ne sont pas majeures
silio Berlusconi couche avec des mineurs
autrement dit mercredi l'Italie a
organisé des obsèques nationales pour un
prédateur sexuel il m'a permis de faire
sur la 5 une de mes meilleures émissions
qui s'appelait bain de minuit et je dois
dire qu'il m'a foutu une paix royale et
qui m'a donné beaucoup d'argent
en hôtel du temps lui il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire
le cinéma italien il a un peu tué le
séminin italien ça c'est vrai la tête
qu'il a là on n'arriverait pas à la
refaire avec l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement il s'agit d'une séquence
créée vient logiciel de création 3D pas
de panique donc Dominique vous pouvez
être assuré merci beaucoup Cyril
stadeler
les gens qui fait quoi est-ce que les
lesbiennes est-ce que c'est des par tous
à 3 est-ce que on savait pas et en fait
la vérité était toute simple c'est que
Dali était un puissante donc il y avait
pas de sexe du tout et ce qui
l'intéressait c'était d'avoir une jeune
muse il a besoin de cette présence voilà
un nouveau lieu à découvrir et en même
temps
chaleur qui rime souvent avec un
moustique c'est quoi votre chanson de
l'année préférée pour vous votre artiste
préféré
oui en plus voilà récompenser mais il
était pas en compétition mais c'est pas
très grave c'est bien vous l'avez vous
l'avez soutenu vous voyez ce reportage
de Victor Bastard et le riz des organes
petit problème technique
oui qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire
mademoiselle damso je crois qu'il est
pas complètement est-ce que tu passes
une bonne soirée
tous ensemble ouais
unanime unanime
tous ensemble tous ensemble ouais les
rues du Mans envahit par la pluie cet
après-midi des orages ont éclatées dans
la Sarthe en Normandie également au
centre ville de Dieppe les habitants se
sont retrouvés les pieds dans l'eau à
quelques kilomètres de là à Motteville
le stade a été touché une toiture s'est
envolée et un arbre s'est couché sur la
route
Emmanuel m'a dit
fraise sublime ça fait rêver ça fait
rêver
froid sur le plateau
climatique
le pape François
parce que par exemple il est pour que
les immigrés viennent et les cathos qui
sont souvent droites disent mais en fait
c'est lui le vrai chrétien c'est pas
c'est pas ceux qui refusent des émigrés
pas sans problème